[موسيقى]
مرحبا نبدا كواليس بكواليس حفل تريو راس
السنه اللي اقيم في الرياض وضم عدد كبير
من النجوم او النجمات فبخلاف ما شاهدناه
على المسرح روى الاعلامي فراس حليمه واللي
كان مرافق للنجمات طوال الايام التحضير
للحفل الاجواء اجتماع النجمات معا مؤكدا
انه ما يحكي عنه طوال الوقت عن خلافات لم
يكن سواه بفعل الفانز وان الواقع عكس ذلك
تماما وقال حليمه نجوم التسعينات هم ركزات
الفن العربي اليوم وهذا الجيل الفني لن
يتكرر واغاني حقبه التسعينات والسنوات
الاولى من الالفيه الثانيه هي اللي راح
تبقى راسخه في وجدان الناس ولكنه كما اكد
انه مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي هي منبع
المشاكل ما بين النجوم وبشكل خاص بين
الفنانه بعيدا عن حروب الفازات العلاقات
راها ممتازه بين الجميع ووصف المشهديه بين
المجموعات بالراقيه وانه علاقات جميله
تجمعهم في التعاون بينهم في المحادثات
الجانبيه وحتى في اصغر التفاصيل
لانه الايجابيه والمحبه والرقي كانوا
ظاهرين بشكل
[موسيقى]
وجه الناقد طارق الشناوي رساله للمخرجه
ساندرا نشات والفنانه الكبيره يحيى
الفخراني يطالبهم فيها باحياء احدى وصايا
الكاتبه الكبير الراحل وحيد حامل حيث طلب
من ساندرا نشات البعيد عن السينما من عشر
سنوات ومن الفخراني بعيد عن السينما من 25
سنه تحويل فيلم كان وحيد حامد كتبوا اسمه
الصحبه الحلوه وكان حلمه انه تكون سند
نشات باخراجه بينما يلعب بطوله يحيى
الفخراني
انه اخر فيلم ليحيى اللي هو مبروك وبلبل
هو اول فيلم روائي طويل
يعني حتى في بينهم شيء مشتركه
معنا
وحقق رغبه وحيد حامد ويقدموا له همم
صحبه ورد مش صحبه الحلوه
عشان قوي يا ايضا تحدث عن شيرين اللي راقب
انها كانت الاقل حظا فنيا في عام 2002 و20
متمنيا ان تعود للنشاط عن المعتاد خاصه
وانها فرعيه الاوفر حابا بمحبه الجمهور
الحب والحب الوجه الاخر للحب اهو المغفره
الجمهور العربي عموما يغفر لمن يحبك حاجات
كثيره جدا عندها شيك طبعا
بيبقى لها رصيد
من
توقعاتها كبير
[موسيقى]
شخصيات اسطوره الرياضه السعوديه ماجد عبد
الله حيث كشف الدوخي ولي اول مره انه هذا
النجاح كان احد اسبابه وماجد عبد الله
نفسه واللي شارك في تحضير فيصل الدوخي
لاداء شخصيته على المسرح المسرحيه انتهى
عرضها مؤخرا واستعرضت ابرز محطات ماجد عبد
الله وقام بتقمص دوري الممثل فيصل الدوخي
اللي اكد انه قام باصعب الادوار اللي
قداها حمودي حمانا التحضيرات انطلقت قبل
العرض بشهر حيث تتعاون معه ماجد عبدالله
الكثير من الاتصالات الهاتفيه معظمها كان
عن طريق التصرف ومع عائلته واصدقائه
انا عندي النسبه حق ماجد
عبد الله لازم
معنا اذا كنت
بنسبه
تساءل جمهور عن التغيير الكبير اللي طلع
على علاء الفنان محمد رمضان واللي حققت
حلقته مع منى الشاذلي الاخيره نسبه مشاهده
عاليه بسبب تصريحاته اللي يعبر فيها عن
ندموا على طريقه اداره قضيته مع الطيار
الراحل اشرف ابو اليسر واعتبار وعند ذلك
ايضا عن تفهموا اللي غضب الشارع من عشر
سنوات بسبب دوره عبده مؤته وانه لم يكن
بعملها هذا الدور انه عاد به الزمن وانه
لقب نمبر وان واستفز فعلا لزملاء النجوم
وما كان يجب ان يطلق على نفسه الجمهور
تسال عن اسباب تغير لازم في رمضان واعرائه
وما اذا كانت اداره اعمال وقد تغيرت الا
اننا في كواليس علمنا بانه فريق محمد
رمضان لا زعلت نفسه لكن نفسه على السعاده
الجماهيريت من جديد ونجاح اعماله القادمه
خاصه مسلسل العمده مع المخرج محمد سامي
والمرتقى في رمضان القادم جعلته حساباته
من جديد ويقوم بدراسه ارائهم مواقفه مجددا
وان هذا ما سيكون عليه الحال خلال ساعه
القادمه